Mr Beast yeah what'd you learn from Mr
Beast because I'm kind of everything but
I'm kind of like
Amazed by him because I can't work out
whether it's work rate or creativity or
like openness to trying new things or
attention to detail and then I watched a
vlog the other day that says he
basically lives in the factory that he
bought that has all of his different
studios in so he's obviously super
committed super committed what'd you
learn from Mr Beast
um how to run a brothel a lot of people
don't know that about him but okay [ __ ]
loves like you know how he's like big on
the hamburgers that's not the only meat
that he's slanging bro this guy sells
bodies man like men and women just
Gigolos and hookers like he's an equal
opportunity he's very equal 100
everybody's allowed but loves selling
sex big into it okay yeah so that's yeah
that's how that's how imagine the
production quality of Mr BEAST's only
fans
oh you got to see it in person bro we'll
go to North Carolina 6K 3D VR dude yeah
what should be up on say again if you
ever watch VR porn no because I've had
sex before yeah well yeah yeah look I
advise you in real life I advise I
advise doing it doing it once just so
that you can see the future demise of
this civilization is that good well it's
like this it's like there yeah it's like
yeah like right there yeah yeah yeah
it's like pretty terrifying yeah or yeah
I don't know I'm not a big porn guy but
to be honest Mr abuse is the
[ __ ] goat and like the way that
he's I mean just everything and he's
also very gracious with information like
he's shares non-stop like you can ask
him for assistance on things and he's
like yeah do this do that blah blah blah
and uh he's just he's just great his
whole team is great I mean Tariq is
great like all those guys are awesome
they analyze the hell out of what makes
videos work for attention on YouTube and
then they create those things and it's
just
yeah he's I can't say enough great
things about outside of the the hookers
thing that he loves yep slinging dick
yeah yeah it seems to me like dude big
dick dude how much full skin bro you
know he doesn't like foreskin that's
another thing okay he doesn't he like uh
what he'll do is he'll bread them and
make like calamari out of him so like he
has this cool rest that's the new
restaurant that he's made where he has
breaded foreskins and then he sells him
his columns Beast skin yeah be skin be
skin yeah it's crazy that you know that
how do you know that uh uh I saw the
trademark got yeah issued online uh but
outside of that like selling parts of
dick like baby dick at that
he's a great guy how many calories are
in baby dick honestly dude
I don't believe in baby dick calories
either to be honest to be completely
honest with you dude I don't believe in
it full skin calories yeah unreal
calories yeah I don't know I don't know
I don't know I'll have to ask yeah you
could imagine a world in which Mr Beast
using like analytics and this sort of
reverse engineering what do we know that
works and I spend 10 grand on a
thumbnail and I do this stuff to end up
with quite a formulaic and like stodgy
feeling
production yep but it doesn't still it
just feels on changing it but it still
feels like creative and open and fluid
and stuff like that
um that seems pretty like almost
impossible to do oh it seems like the
the balance that is very difficult to
strike of course because there's a bunch
of YouTubers that can make the formulaic
like this is my process and this is how
it will work and I'll rinse and repeat
but then to do that which you know works
and then keep it fresh success is
seductive it's very hard to move away
from success and guaranteed success is a
thing that you've already been doing
very well so him doing a new type of
video or a new genre a new platform
actually creates longevity right like
but at the same time it's dangerous you
know it's a dangerous thing to do he
could flop and when he flops it's big
think about like Hollywood won't even
make a new movie
we're on Mission Impossible nine like
that's you know what I'm saying like
there's no new movies because they're
worried about the amount of money that
they're spending not being returned to
them and uh so that's why I like yeah I
got a lot of respect for for Jimmy and
the boys man in other news this episode
is brought to you by whoop it is the
best fitness tracker that I have ever
found it's the only one that I've ever
stuck with and it tracks absolutely
everything from my sleep to my recovery
even the workouts that I do every single
day through this strap which is on 24 7.
my resting heart rate my heart rate
variability and even how much I'm
breathing throughout the night tells me
my quality of sleep it gives me trends
and reports over time but the most
important thing is it actually nudges my
behavior through suggestions in an app
it's a digital coach not just a fitness
tracker and it encourages me to change
my behavior that will improve my health
over the long term even better than that
you can join for free pay nothing for
the brand new whoop 4.0 strap and get
your first month for free so you buy it
for free try it for free and if you do
not like it after 29 days they'll give
you your money back head to
join.woop.com Modern wisdom to sign up
right now that's join.woop.com
modern wisdom what's happening people if
you enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace
[Music]